letztlich zu russland in ausgesprochener
nicht sein kann das nicht sein darf das
bevor er kanzler wurde in der spd aber
zeigen
rein
demokratischen staates macht er hat es
zu unterstützen
nord stream zwei vertretern gesprochen
und dieses dilemma wird fatalerweise
möglichkeit ist natürlich dass der neue
nicht die vorstellung gemacht dass ein
gerade heute noch mal herr sigmar
sind ja mittlerweile längst unsere
doch das reicht nicht sagt der der die
lassen in anführungszeichen lupenreiner
engführung das waren die verhältnisse
ihnen lagen drei änderungen am herzen
auch einmal in aller klarheit gesagt als
agiert seit vielen jahren schon als
formel prägte sie schon 1963 wandel
auch spätestens dann mit seinem abgang
oder umgekehrt was nicht sein darf das
eigentlichen nachbarn und das in diesem
nicht durch einen kanzler aufgelöst der
kanzler olaf scholz eine überzeugende
schon von gerhard schröder übrigens ein
sozialdemokratie seit wochen vor sich
derartiges menschheitsverbrechen nicht
guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
demokrat
die ich eingefügt und gelb markiert habe
seine devise sein letztes stündchen als
nicht sein kann also wann wollte diese
er gefragt wurde was machen sie denn
politik macht in dem augenblick in dem
ich würde gern noch mal auf dieses thema
skandal sondergleichen dass er in
gabriel ist der völlig falsche maniche
geschäftsmann wir sollten damit aufhören
augenblick fallen die betrachtungen
hertreibt wie kein anderer der
durch annäherung also entspannungs
hat letztlich wie er immer gesagt hat
wenn sie nicht mehr kannst da sind dann
nur im er in der östlichen asiatischen
geschäfte mit russland machen man hat
als die stiftung dann beschlossen ist
er deutlich macht wie er sich anders
engster weise mit dem angeblich
ihn als elder statesman als altkanzler
er seinen abgang zelebrierte du it my
zwischen von polen ungarn und in vielen
einem draufkommen dass eben die spd ja
kurz das mal ab sondern eben vor allem
die führung übernehmen müsste wer bei
live spd altkanzler schröder gibt ein
sagt er in aller klarheit ich will geld
ukrainische botschafter melnik
wider besseres wissen hat man letztlich
lupenreinen demokraten wladimir putin
verhält in dem er auch wirklich die
politik statt der damaligen abschottung
wahrzunehmen und wir hatten gerhard
lobt ein nord stream vertreter die
anderen staaten und der sowjetunion bzw
raum tschetschenien syrien möglich ist
verdient man muss sich also ein stück
provoziert die genossen mit tweets wie
für die eigene partei der er zusammen
way ich denke an mich mit der alten
mir führung bestellt der bekommt sie
befreundet ist und kein rückzug davon
richtlinien der politik bestimmt indem
denkwürdiges interview in der new york
zwischen west und ost aufeinander
stadtkanzlei das hat doch alles sehr gut
auch so das wort von olaf scholz es gibt
gerade vor allem auch die pipeline nord
weit auch ehrlich machen an dem punkt
diesem an sigmar gabriel gerichtet
im nachfolgestaat russland radikal
mit dem so nennt er ihnen freundchen
sondern eben auch in europa dass putin
macht er ist ausdruck der tatsache dass
schröder ja klar aufgefordert viele
devise wenn jeder an sich denkt ist an
schröder hat einem nie in unklarheit
er führungsfähigkeit zeigt unterläuft er
stream 2 noch gebaut nachdem die krim
also eine in sich zerrissene
zugehen stadt die fronten verhärten als
auseinander aber die so die spd hat bis
times und sagt er bereut nichts
geklappt ein ganz normaler vorgang sagt
großartig ist vor allem ihre und ihrer
schröder einen enormen schaden zufügt
alle gedacht ich gehe meinen eigenen weg
mit einer solchen brutalität und
jahre gemacht hat stadt so hat auch
diese partei immer sehr viel auf
viele ehemalige parteivorsitzende lars
sozialdemokratie die nicht klar ist der
gelassen er hat sich übrigens auch immer
natürlich in hohem maße die kritiker
erobert worden war das heißt wir wollten
mecklenburg vorpommerns spd
horst radetzky auf facebook geschrieben
aussöhnung mit der es mit der mit
und letztlich hat man den eindruck das
letztlich der ukraine das existenzrecht
spd kumpane jahrelang putin freundliche
dann wird es ein wenig nicht immer so
dagegen verwahrt als altkanzler
oder den tweet von vorhin der spd hat
die ministerpräsidentin
nicht klar ist wo die reise hingehen
klingbeil und ich seine mandate bei den
heute nicht richtig in jeder hinsicht
ob der guten geschäfte mit russland
russland gehalten hat eigentlich in
staatssekretär war bar ab 1969 der
angesprochen zu werden er hat ein stück
ministerpräsidentin schwesig gerät wegen
ist ja auch das erstaunliche die
das damals die landesregierung mit
sind doch nicht nur spd politiker nach
leicht sein von angeblicher kumpanei zu
soll die in diesem punkt sehr unbestimmt
auch den ukrainern und ukrainern selbst
keinen keil in dieses verhältnis treiben
sich noch gar nicht verabschiedet von
politik gewesen shame on you
fortschreibung das verhältnis zur union
russischen konzernen niederzulegen das
die erkenntnis verinnerlicht dass die
ministern und auch ministerpräsidentin
weit den hut des altkanzlers in dem
geschichtsbücher was von ihm eines tages
nord stream zwei immer weiter unter
ihrer ruhmlosen russland vergangenheit
sprechen und wirklich zum teil sogar zu
ist insofern ist also das problem der
moskau gepilgert auch cdu politiker
wäre notwendig gewesen um sein ansehen
das existenzrecht absprechen vorgehen
architekt dieses konzept und willy
und am offensichtlichsten sie haben es
und wenn man die verhältnisse nun
gespräche führt hat über ein großes
hart zu schießen das ist die eigentlich
bleibt ist ihm völlig egal also eine
das eine ist fehler einzuräumen und
augenblick als er das kanzleramt
ich glaube dass diese partei sich noch
vergangenheit das eine ich würde da auch
druck und spd kanzler scholz wird
nachbarn zuallererst natürlich diese
waren genauso da merkel und so weiter
gesehen hat sowohl von herrn steinmeier
würde das glaube ich war den meisten
brandt baute darauf seine kanzlerschaft
benannt war natürlich mecklenburg
verlassen hat hinter sich gelassen
als ehemaliger und eines deutlich
etwas anderes ist heute richtige
notwendigkeit ein stück weit geht es
nicht immer darauf beharren wollen dass
genannten zwischen staaten sind polen
wirtschaftsprojekt was ja unser land
zunehmend als zu zögerlich wahrgenommen
abgelegt und wurde zum geschäftsmann zum
derartige ignoranz gegenüber dem
zu herrn langdorf als dem aus münchen
vorpommern an der spitze mit manuela
nicht ganz verabschiedet hat von dieser
erfolgreicher bundeskanzler zu retten
heute in der politik nicht mehr primär
beispielsweise das allergrößte angst hat
schlüsse daraus zu ziehen und mutig zu
betroffen hat ist auch
diese partei sich explizit entschuldigen
schwesig weil dieses land am
aber wieso ist es jetzt tatsächlich so
insofern haben wir uns so müssen wir uns
um die vergangenheitsbewältigung die
selbstverständlich keine konsequenzen
ist er übrigens noch nach beginn des
bei der zeitenwende die er selbst
handlungsreisende ich mir putin der in
jetzt der nächste opfer statt zu werden
handeln das heißt eben auch endlich
allerstärksten von der pipeline
nachleben ist in einem solchen maße
leider ist er diesem rat nicht gefolgt
eingestehen uns alle ein stück weit
muss es ist schon auch wahr dass herr
ukraine des krieges gegen die ukraine
profitiert wir haben dazu einen
aller den brutalitäten übrigens und das
ruhmlosen vergangenheit und auch keine
politik wir sagten ist am anfang der
keine aufarbeitung die spd-führung
angekündigt hat die spd und ihr
tschechien ungarn et cetera umwelt
schwere waffen sofort an die ukraine zu
dass diese diese es gut dass die spd
täuschen lassen ich erinnere mich noch
melnik mit gewaltigen kraft begriffen
bemerkenswert dass das natürlich für die
und sie hat ja ganz klar gesagt dass
mit der eroberung der krim und andere
macht ja auch dieses große stück in new
sehr genau wie der bundestag im jahr
kommentar von christa tebbe auf facebook
allerdings mit herrn orban in
verweigert die klärung ihres russland
verhältnis zu russland seit beginn des
aussöhnung und der verständigung mit der
diese diese ganze schuld quasi an sich
vorgeht also wenn er von der kumpanei
spd insgesamt ein riesiges problem ist
liefern herr von lucke warum hat sich
schlüsse gezogen hat für die zukunft
york times deutlich der heute bereit ist
es folgten in den 70ern gewalt
verhältnisse dann wird man feststellen
schröder bitte aus der partei austreten
2001 frenetisch fast klatschte als putin
ausgesprochener engführung zu russland
sie schreibt wenn man ständig gewarnt
problems
spricht gegen die spd wenn er davon
müssen ja die spd war in besonderem maße
ukraine kriegs gibt es daran zunehmend
der botschafter gefühl so auf die spd
alle untaten putins ein stück weit zu
sowjetunion hatte ihre berechtigung in
hat die union wie schafft ihr das das so
und ein stück weit eine schande für
soll auf der anderen seite könnte doch
fast anschmiegsam also ich will damit
denn das eine ist fehler einzuräumen was
wird von osteuropa und experten aber
spricht herr steinmeier wäre die spinne
deutschland
verzichtserklärungen mit der sowjetunion
schönen guten abend herr von lucke
sagen die eigene situation dass wir es
seine rede in deutsch nicht ich fand das
aber damit stellt sich doch auch
läuten dann auf die frage hin was ist
einer gewissen phase sie ist jetzt
trotzdem weitermacht mit putin und
zweifel denn der blick auf viele dinge
auch die partei einen
eng an russland und vor allem sie hat
alles von sich weg zu drücken naja es
im spinnennetz einer putin lobby gewesen
anerkennung der grenzen ein miteinander
damals schon leicht irritierend aber ihm
eingeschossen
ausschlussverfahren gegen ihn starten
russland kriege ignoriert dann mit wir
wir jetzt passierten tag hören und etwas
mit butscher auf sich hat den großen
100 fahrzeuge die
obsolet es gilt neue konsequenzen zu
mit einer trennung zu tun hatten auf der
eigentlich die frage ob man der ganzen
na ja wir haben es ja jetzt
hat sich einfach geändert darüber wollen
das sind schon sehr harte attacken und
ist eben auch dem umstand geschuldet wir
jetzt allergrößte schwierigkeiten sich
warum passiert das noch nicht weil es
ist es tatsächlich gelungen mit einer
einen seite die östliche hemisphäre die
verbrechen der russischen armee in jetzt
gewissermaßen raus gehört die logik ist
demonstrativ zwischen brand und
sache und der person an sich vielleicht
haben uns geirrt reagiert dass es zu
wir haben diesen betrag eben gesehen was
man fragt sich ein bisschen warum melnik
ziehen es geht vor allem auf die
haben es ja gerade gehört woher die
davon abzusetzen weil eben diese
man nicht andere leute weil auch in der
deutschen ansprache ein stückweit weite
wir heute abend sprechen und deshalb
anderes ist auch tatsächlich zu handeln
wirklichen nachbarn die nächsten
sehr banal weil die spd den kanzler
breschnjew und später auch zwischen
natürlich ein historischer vorfall
attacken kommen wenn herr melnik sich
wenig und zu dürftig noch nicht mal eine
situation des kalten krieges kriege
nicht auch einfach viel zu viel
denken sie sind das jetzt alles einzelne
beziehung anders als bei der cdu csu ein
nicht diesen vorwurf auf die anderen
in der ukraine sagt er nur schlicht das
nachbarn polen
würden wir uns freuen wenn sie uns ihre
auf die spd ein schießt und die
stellt was die spd die eigentlich
teile des landes um die finger zu
diese debatte jeder der mann mit den
beispielloser art wäre und wir wissen
parteien wie gesagt auch die taz darin
aufmerksamkeit widmet angesichts der
tschechien und viele andere rücksicht zu
stück weit die identität dieser partei
durch auseinandersetzung durch die
muss man untersuchen putin geht er noch
meinungen und kommentare und ihre fragen
unions kanzler kohl und gorbatschow die
wirkliche entschuldigung also sie sehen
kanzlerin beispielsweise sehr
schwierigkeiten die man individuell
wickeln und das wird auch ein thema sein
stärkste kraft in der regierung ist und
explizit und die deutsche wirtschaft
alle wie schwierig es ist personen wegen
atombombe das prinzip der abschreckung
russen geredet hat ist jetzt gleich kurz
tatsache dass es so viele
ungeschoren lässt dann ist es klar dass
ausmacht entspannungs politik gehört
nehmen und ihre bedürfnisse zu sehen
weiter würde den krieg ja am liebsten
aussehen das ist von daher schon
schicken würden das können sie gerne
es gibt auch userin die einschätzung
betrachten muss oder steckt der fehler
das sind sicherlich noch jahre
da ist es natürlich höchst opportun für
ausgeschlossen war und auf der anderen
parteischädigenden verhaltens das
davor kriegsverbrecher zu sein wie war
es an der spd bleibt und ich sagte ja
schwerwiegendere probleme gibt aktuell
beenden man fragt sich wo er dieses
wenn das der kanzler neue macht und
beschäftigen wird lassen sie uns auf
förmlich zu dna und deshalb fällt ihr
bemerkenswert dass die spd sich zum teil
einfach in die kommentarspalten
im system
einen botschafter der er selber ganz
braucht ist ja für einen ausschuss
seite derwesten das ist obsolet und
das doch hanebüchen mal mit den russen
wissen her hat und er hätte nur ein
ermöglichten dann die deutsche einheit
besser macht als bisher eher nachdem man
absolut teilen jetzt ist es ja so dass
eindeutig gesagt hat er agiert momentan
da steckt natürlich ganz grundsätzlich
einen der bekanntesten köpfe der spd
absolut da sagen sie etwas völlig
letztlich aus der partei zu bugsieren
schreiben oder sie schicken uns eine e
jetzt die absetzung so schwer kann über
davon distanziert aber es bleibt
auch bereits bei der spd ist es durchaus
mittlerweile haben wir diese staaten die
in der tat nach der zeitenwende die er
gewisses gewisse probleme so suppo
weniger als botschafter denn als der
geredet sigmar gabriel war zwischen 2015
mail an die adresse diese jetzt gerade
schauen auf altkanzler schröder der ja
der eiserne vorhang gefallen wandel
zum beispiel parteichef klingen weil
richtig ist und es ist das muss man aber
wir haben es im falle sarrazin erlebt
natürlich ein ganz grundsätzliches
mehr identitäts bestandteil sie ist auch
der fehler im system aber wir müssen das
altkanzler schröder werden wir gleich
angst vor russland haben und die
verkündet hat konkrete politik wie zu
schröder zu putin die müssten noch
auch sehr deutlich sagen ein stück weit
problem es ist einerseits ein urlaub
eingeblendet sehen der
dieses konzept wandel durch annäherung
wie schwierig und wie langwierig der
mann der versucht für die ukraine waffen
am wochenende dieses interview in der
noch viel grundsätzlicher begreifen denn
natürlich das hat der kollege gesagt in
in dem punkt von der ideologie her oder
ausgeräumt werden ja man kann sich
noch mal sprechen sie haben es aber
auch ganz massiv das schlechte gewissen
vorgang war und im falle schröder wäre
durch annäherung schielein spd gemacht
und 2017 als damaliger wirtschafts und
wenig gesehen hat auch viel zu wenig
politikwissenschaftler albrecht von
scholz der nicht klar position bezieht
als gescheitert erklärt hat und auch
aufzutreiben worüber wo immer es geht
vorstellen welche probleme das
von der grundüberzeugung dem idealismus
ein system gibt es in zweierlei hinsicht
new york times gegeben hat wir können
eine ausbeutung dieser dieser
es natürlich noch viel dramatischer man
lucke wird uns heute abend seine
der spd und da ist sie leider wirklich
offensichtlich sind offen sich die wir
und es bleibt natürlich die ungeheure
reichen die ursprünge eben in die zeit
das erfolgsmodell auch nach 1990 mit
das ist ja auch aus der lage heraus
früherer art könnte man sogar sagen sie
später außenminister quasi im dauer
zeitenwende wenn das der kanzler besser
bundespräsident steinmeier hat gesagt
wladimir putin und übrigens alles klar
wir haben zunächst einmal und das ist
das mal zeigen ja hier die mit der
putin bis zum 9 mai dem tag des sieges
muss sich das vorstellen die spd
einschätzungen und seine informationen
hypothek eines ehemaligen kanzlers
ist angreifbar sie ist eben auch die
des kalten krieges zurück und mein
verständlich es ist eine fatale lage für
haftbar zu machen beziehungsweise da
gespräch mit gazprom und nord stream wie
versucht einen eigenen kanzler aus der
macht dann wird ein stück weit auch die
verkünden er hat die texte bereits im
und eingeräumt dass er als außenminister
die völlig über gelagerte systemfrage
einer fehlkalkulation sie heißt wladimir
der sowjetunion im großen
geben bevor wir aber los legen lassen
gerhard schröder der nach wie vor an
überschrift der frühere kanzler der eben
letzten jahr geschrieben man hätte sie
kollege thomas garcia hat uns da mal
regierungspartei und ein glück hat die
die ukraine er begreift sich als ein
trifft es sie bis ins mark es war
partei zu werfen das ist so beispiellos
fehler in der russland politik gemacht
alte spd politiker entspannungs politik
termin protokolle seien er sorgte unter
bloß ernst nehmen müssen deutlich machte
sie uns kurz den beitrag von christiane
ein system bundesrepublik und in der
vaterländischen krieg er will noch so
cdu/csu obendrein sie hat es mit einem
mann der in sicherheit lebt der wein
einen kleinen überblick geschaffen damit
allen beziehungen zu putin festhält der
hat also es gibt ja durchaus
beispielsweise erklingen bei der neue
putins man in deutschland wurde und in
viel boden gewinne machen wie möglich um
ich bin mit dem ende der sowjetunion
dass das allein natürlich eine ungeheure
putin
sein land den schlimmsten angriffen
ihr kuscheln mit putin es wird ein stück
hübscher und bernd benthin schauen die
bundesrepublik war ist beileibe nicht
anderem mit dafür dass deutsche
wir da auch alle gleichermaßen im bilde
parteivorsitzende er noch vor einem jahr
jetzt neuen parteivorsitzenden zu tun
selbstkritische stimmen in der partei
seinen job bei gazprom nicht aufgibt im
nicht einverstanden ich will den alten
dann vielleicht zu waffenstillstands
aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen würde die
gasspeicher an gazprom verkauft werden
ausgesetzt aber es hängt natürlich auch
sind egon bahr er war der vater der
weit relativiert und dann zählt die
nur die spd die letztlich seit
seinen freund schröder als einzigen der
uns dieses schwierige beziehungsgeflecht
diesem interview sagt schröder so sätze
gegenteil der weiter lautstark verkündet
der in der tat für sich reklamieren kann
warum hat man trotzdem den eindruck dass
status der soll nun wieder herstellen
gesprächen zu kommen also schröder ist
spd hat also hart gesprochenes nur die
schröder machte nur bei ihm einen
nur ein jahr nach der annexion decke der
der am kollege thomas ganze hat es eben
wie
gegenwart wieder mehr und das ist auch
jahrzehnten ein glänzendes auskommen mit
den blick weil man sehr deutlich merkt
noch mal aufzeigen
dass er 20 jahre lang nicht mehr
eigentlich für putin alles gute im
wahl zwischen pest und cholera also ein
wahlkampfauftritt es war noch martin
unter inanspruchnahme der ukraine in
längst zu einem reinen legitim ator
ich mach hier nicht einen auf mehr
die motivation
dringend erforderlich wir werden das
es ist eine gewisse instrumentalisierung
dass russland problem von olaf scholz
schilde ich werde mich davon nicht
schulz der noch im jahre 2017 drei
bundespolitik gemacht hat friedrich merz
den russischen gaslieferungen hatte man
schon angesprochen weil eigentlich
gerhard schröder als geschäftsmann in
verkennung oder bzw nichtachtung der
der wahrheitsfindung also debatte über
wladimir putins geworden und insofern
historiker jan behrens verzweifelt an
sehr genau beobachten vielen dank
akzeptieren das ist natürlich für diese
kultur mehr culpa also meine schuld das
der ja sogar ein gegner von angela
hat viele gesichter
der partei zu behalten mit all seinen
wandel durch annäherung daran klingt
jahren nach der in dem überfall
könnte genauso gut die deutsche
ukraine in dem augenblick spätestens
seiner eigenen partei er gehört zur
albrecht von lucke und noch einen
ist die eigentlich entscheidende frage
auseinanderzusetzen nicht so richtig da
die deutsche vergangenheit die auch mit
merkel ist ist in der hinsicht ein eher
spd zu tief schädlich und übrigens ich
wirtschaft fragen man hätte auch jede
einflussreiche spd gesichter aktive und
stand daten gegenüber putin oder ihn aus
ist nicht mein ding
erstmal gut daran ist erstmal nichts
schönen abend ihnen tschüss ich danke
russlands auf der krim der noch dem
hätte man erkennen müssen ja im jahre
einem ganz konkreten anlass betrieben
auch an uns alle warum kann ein solcher
geschichte kommission der spd fordert
veranlassung angela merkel die sich ja
will das haupt formulieren auch eine
ist
unbeschriebenes blatt aber im kern geht
woher kommt beim altkanzler herr von
der partei zu werfen was kaum möglich
auszusetzen aber wann kam dann der punkt
2014 allerspätestens mit der besetzung
ihnen schönen abend
ich glaube in der tat dass sie zum teil
bewusst in schweigen hüllt zu fragen
wird die spd und in der spitze natürlich
gewisse schande für ein land das
ehemalige viele nicht alle gestehen
seit jahren einen anderen kurs
damals schon den putz den handlanger von
mann der auch letztlich nicht mehr als
es um noch etwas viel grundsätzlicheres
ist und insofern glaube ich wird auch
wo dieses konzept schief gelaufen ist
denn sie war natürlich die frau die über
gegenwärtig erleben muss dass ein
ja und auch in vielen dank fürs
auch hier müssen wir uns das bewusst
der krim da hätte man sehen müssen hier
auch den deutschen bundeskanzler massiv
geschichtlich auf die vergangenheit
putin gebenden gerhard schröder zum
kanzler der bundesrepublik auftritt
jetzt einen historischen irrtum ein aber
lucke dieser unwille sich mit dem
ehemaliger kanzler ein kriegsverbrecher
sagen dass da moment gemauert wird und
die letzten 16 jahre die allermeisten
machen wir alle hätten das ganze land ab
unter druck zu setzen oder vor allem
das hat eine ganz banale ursache und die
bezogen stärker manchmal ist als man es
gerhard schröder diesem ansinnen von
sind staaten zu schützen aber damit hat
dabeisein ich möchte noch den hinweis
hauptredner des parteitages machte also
sondern nur noch als privatmann wie er
unterstützt das ist fatal
gespräch mit wladimir putin geführt hat
eigenen handeln kritisch
auch nicht mehr ich habe mich nicht
noch weit mehr eben frank walter
so wahrnimmt das große problem ist ein
ascon was ja sie formuliert er möge doch
selber unumwunden sagt warum kann dieser
ich will damit sagen diese ganze partei
sozusagen dieser aufarbeitungsprozess
geben morgen melden wir uns wieder mit
auseinanderzusetzen
geht über eine personelle betrachtung
das ist also zunächst einmal die
die spd viel zu lange gezögert sie ist
steinmeier als den bundespräsidenten es
übrigens haben wir einige spd
dem tschetschenienkrieg eigentlich
entschuldigt ich habe gesagt dass das
anderes die spd hat ja auch ein
systemfrage in der wir übrigens auch
zdf heute live dann werden nach wir nach
nicht in gang gesetzt wird weil man wohl
sind das die persönlichen interessen der
mann noch heute ein von uns allen
frank walter steinmeier zu einer erst
bitte bitte aus der partei austreten mit
hinaus wir müssen uns bewusst machen im
wissen können was putin im schilde führt
ging ja sogar so weit dass herr
alle nicht ganz unbeteiligt sind die
zu anschmiegsam geblieben aber in der
eine fehleinschätzung gewesen ist die
gegenwart problem die große frage ist ja
der bundespräsident der seine ganze
politikerinnen und politiker gefragt ob
finanziertes büro mit diversen stellen
jahr 89 90 mit dem zerfall der
weiter verfolgt mit gazprom und rosneft
auch fürchtet dass viele karrieren da
ramstein schauen zur us
sicherheit nicht nachkommen er weiß doch
das massenmorden in tschetschenien ich
steinmeier der das angebot gemacht hatte
tat auch unter einer regierung merkel
fehleinschätzung dass wir und auch ich
deutsche bevölkerung hat diese beiden
karriere ja maßgeblich gerhard schröder
was macht die spd in der gegenwärtigen
dranhängen und das dann sozusagen ja ein
ganz genau dass diese rolle des pfarrers
sie heute abend bei uns im stream auch
besetzen beziehungsweise wird auf diese
sowjetunion ist das große wort von willy
parteien die am stärksten dahin gewirkt
die richter auch nicht wesentlich anders
verdankt diese ganze partei steht ein
luftwaffenbasis dort treffen sich
oder ist das ein falscher stolz was ist
nach kiew zu reisen förmlich ausgeladen
erinnere mich noch genau wie er damals
verhalten hat lassen sie uns dann noch
zu dass sein möchten das hat irgendwie
die ja in gewisser weise im ansehen
haben nämlich die cdu csu wie auch die
gedacht haben dass es ein fehler war
situation und da streiten sich ganz
persönlichkeiten auch beschädigt werden
weise finanziert das ist eigentlich ein
sagte ich kriege die terroristen noch in
stückweit natürlich noch im banne dieses
wurde das ist schon ein besonderer
vertreterinnen und vertreter vieler
brandt was ja aus seiner ersten
mal kurz ein haken sie sagen man hätte
bei keinem geklappt heute abend das nur
die heute noch politik machen natürlich
auch ein fehler von mir dieses projekt
völlig unhaltbarer zustand und immerhin
offensichtlich in der partei noch immer
spd in großer mehrheit gewählt das heißt
gewonnen hat in der bevölkerung
regierungserklärung von 969 stammte wir
jeder toilette wird zerdrücken sie noch
länder um über den ukraine krieg zu
vorgang aus der kriegssituation
das es wird nur die persönlichen
sehen müssen hat man es vielleicht
letzten ihrer kanzler werden wir jetzt
mittlerweile erziele dass diese
beispiel manuela schwesig die
zwei linien für die eine eben die das
haben diverse der angestellten längst
in der toilette übrigens bei anschlägen
emotional nachvollziehbar weil man sagt
wollen ein volk der guten nachbarn seien
fürs protokoll
dieses system wir haben von billigem gas
gesehen und hat man es nicht sehen
interessen und das war übrigens bei gerd
mitgliedschaft ihnen ein stück weit noch
von olaf scholz absehen und das macht es
beraten davon werden wir berichten
bei denen gemutmaßt wird dass er sie
wir haben gefragt lassen sie uns beim
beharren auf der entspannungs politik
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
ihren konsequenzen gezogen und sind
herr steinmeier hatte sehr enge
wollen oder weil man möglicherweise auch
ein wort was nicht mehr primär zum
schröder eigentlich im augenblick des
profitiert die deutsche wirtschaft hat
selber initiiert hat um auf diese weise
er schützt er hat bisher nur immer dann
natürlich so prekär für sie deswegen die
wird in aller regel der
ihrerseits ausgezogen beziehungsweise
morgen denn sie mögen für namen
beziehung zu labors und russland aber
vorpommern ließ noch letztes jahr in
ukrainischen botschafter in deutschland
abgangs klar wer in einer solchen mal
zu naiv
fraktionsvorsitzender rolf mützenich
glänzende geschäfte gemacht und russland
den äußeren feind zu kreieren das ging
konsequenzen gezogen beispielsweise von
ostblock in gänze gesprochen wurde denn
haben gekündigt an dem punkt muss auch
versuche jetzt möglich viel distanz
extra eine hoch umstrittene stiftung
dass letztere mit sicherheit wir hatten
verantwortlich gemacht der seit langem
bleiben bei andré melnik vielleicht
natürlich eigentlich höchst unklug denn
habt gesprochen charakterlosigkeit auch
hat uns letztlich in eine abhängigkeit
der ehrenbürgerschaft hannovers
das war ja die zeit des kalten krieges
zwischen sich und den kanzler zu legen
gründen damit die neue pipeline allen us
und das ist durchaus auch
können wir hier mal den 1 anderen tweet
das land sich ein stück weit den vorwurf
dann weiter mit dem syrien krieg wo er
gebracht wie es jetzt brutal ausspielt
ja immer wieder die äußerung und auch da
das zeichen einen deutschen präsidenten
übrigens gegenüber der eigenen partei
da gab es das status quo sieht die
zurückzutreten oder aus der
aber ich bin gespannt er könnte es eher
anerkennenswert erlangen ein mann der
machen dass es letztlich eher herrn
die schlimmsten
mitgliedschaft bei dortmund oder anrufer
muss man leider auch an angela merkel
sofort mit dem ende des eigenen amtes
im krieg gegen die ukraine da sind wir
sanktionen zum trotz fertig gebaut
status quo situation da der eiserne
bombenangriffe tätigte zwar auf
auszuladen der ja deutlich gemacht hätte
so leicht machen er könnte jetzt ja
friedenspolitik ist der grundsätzlich
die frage richten merkel hat oft gesagt
schröder immer auf den leim gegangen ist
96 den beiden fussballvereinen wenn dort
werden konnte e mails zwischen ihrer
alle ein stück weit beteiligt aber das
wirklich sagen wenn ihr mich nicht mehr
einladung des kriegsverbrechers assad
vorhang trennte west und ost und der
wir stehen an der seite der ukraine das
das schreibt auch hier ein user auf
für den abbau von atomwaffen und vieles
ja putin lebt in einer anderen welt also
einen hoch lukrativen deal mit wladimir
haben wollt dann trete ich aus ich bin
zweite system und darauf wollen sie ja
wirklich druck gemacht wurde wenn ein
staatskanzlei und der nord stream ag
ostblock wurde gewissermaßen als eine
youtube schröder müssen die ex-kanzler
andere plädierte also das prinzip der
verfahren gelaufen ist dann ist der
hinaus das zweite system ist natürlich
aber eben doch mit einer ungeheuren
gespannt ob er diese letzte größe
ist auch diplomatisch nicht sehr klug
putins gazprom firma bzw los banos
belegen wie sehr der gazprom-tochter
gesamtheit begriffen der warschauer pakt
privilegien genommen werden keine
abschreckung eigentlich grundsätzlich
sie wird wahrscheinlich am allermeisten
gewissermaßen präventiv ausgestiegen
menschenverachtung will sagen wir alle
gewesen vielleicht dazu noch eine
vielleicht dann doch was ich sehe ist
in gewisser weise in besonderem maße die
umfasste die länder sowjetunion bis
seinen revisionismus seine
konzern dabei mitreden durfte so
verurteilte und genau für diese
interviews mehr mit ihm oder
solange die spd nicht agiert und es gibt
trefft eingeht ist natürlich in einem
haben das gesehen und ich glaube es
momentan nicht hervorlocken damit wäre
einschätzung von manuel preißler auf
spd und das hängt an einer ganz
geschichtsphilosophie bzw seine
irgendwelche bezahlten vorträge eben die
entspannungs politik steht auf der
polen tschechien und so weiter und so
liegt diesem ungeheuren schock ich nenne
eben tatsächlich leider auch gute gründe
entscheidenden tatsache für die spd ist
schreibt der heutige innenminister
youtube die russland-politik war kein
ich auch schon bei meiner letzten frage
geschichte ideologie gehört haben die er
christian pegel damals ich habe mit den
maße angreifbar und macht sich damit zum
fort mit dem ende des kalten krieges ist
es zu unterlassen so lange sehe ich
anderen seite andere jüngere politiker
es den putin schockvideos herausgeber
forderung ihm auch kein forum zu bieten
fehler es war bewusste blindheit putin
letztlich die ukraine völlig leugnet das
wie kann die spd es jetzt schaffen aus
die entspannungs politik quasi der kern
michael roth beispielsweise der frühere
nicht dass gerhard schröder konsequenzen
diener seiner eigenen interessen in dem
berthold kohler es liegt auch eine große
aber plötzlich ein gewissermaßen
parteichefin ascon hat den altkanzler
existenzrecht der ukraine absprache aber
hat innerhalb 24 stunden nach macht
staatssekretär der sehr viel für sehr
ihrer identität dieses verhältnis
dieser verfahrenen situation
zieht er verfolgt eigentlich immer und
er diene oder lack eines anderen des
fehleinschätzung von uns ein davor wir
zwischenraum zwischen russland und
auch sie genau wie sie es sagen war
erneut deutlich kritisiert dann mal kurz
herauszukommen die allerbeste
viel mehr abgrenzung von putin plädiert
immer grosny in schutt und asche legen
wir hätten das frühe merken müssen schon
deutschland und dieser zwischenraum das
präsidenten eines an und nicht gerade
alle uns wahrscheinlich ein stückweit
[Musik]